[Musique]
un million de tracts pour annoncer la
couleur d'une nouvelle candidature d'
emmanuel macron à la présidentielle la
distribution commencera ce week-end ou
rend solidaire à laquelle je rêve et
celle pour laquelle je me bats
l'occasion de cette élection
présidentielle c'est celle qui se
fixerait comme obligation de faire en
sorte que tous les français soient
vaccinés je crois que nous devons
assumer le fait d'être en campagne je
crois que ça n'est pas un gros mot que
de parler de campagne oui nous devons
être en campagne pour défendre notre
bilan oui il faut que tout change
la société française est malade elle est
malade de l'indifférence elle est malade
du travail qui ne paye plus elle est
malade d'une organisation trop
centralisée une mère de famille vient de
remporter deux millions de dollars
uniquement parce qu'elle s'est fait
vacciner elle a reçu ses deux doses au
printemps dernier mais le tirage au sort
vient d'avoir lieu elle n'est pas la
seule gagnante en tous les jours au mois
de juillet l'état du michigan aux frais
50000 $ à 1 vacciner au hasard le
magnifique revient à la une de pas moins
de vingt-cinq quotidiens partout en
crise les adieux à bébel et les rimes
sont toutes faites à bébel éternelle ou
bébel au ciel à noter les une de libé la
vie est belle ou encore le figaro l'as
des as qui revient à la une de trois
autres quotidiens as et est le panache
la gouaille la gueule c'était la france
la france d'avant avec son élégance qui
était comme certains acteurs depardieu
entre autres qui devait péter abraham
vente avant de jouer
tout le monde attendait et après tout
ils encadrent rôle c'était fantastique
savez vous que c'est une chose qui est
assez peu connu lui qu'on commande que
c'était le délégué de la cgt des acteurs
faut effectivement qui ne disait pas ça
fait 6 matin qu'il fait pas la une des
journaux et donc même les acteurs ont
droit à une représentation syndicale
quand il était président de ce syndicat
il expliqué que les acteurs qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent lydie nous on est
traité comme des marque de dentifrice en
revanche il avait eu ce mot pour ces
milliers d'acteurs qui font le spectacle
en france qui ne travaillent que trois
mois à peine mais qui en ont deux mois
pour remplir le frigo et donc qu'il
avait toujours ça à coeur il est 19h
quatrième quand sandrine rousseau
candidate à la primaire écologiste
remercie jean pierre bel mandeau d'avoir
porté haut le cinéma français et elle
ajoute une touche d'humour noir en
espérant que sa dernière cascades n'aura
pas été trop difficile dans un bac et de
l'autre côté de la voiture le cascadeur
rémy julienne pilotes sauf que nombre de
vols quand jean-paul se lève pour monter
et à l'esp est sur le capot de la
voiture il désactive la petite manette
qui donne le contrôle qui donnait le
contrôle à rémy julienne et au final je
crois que je fais souvent de courir et
enfantement que je suis vraiment en
train de conduire
nous n'oublierons jamais je crois de
talent le brio et l'humour légendaire de
ce monument du cinéma et du théâtre
français n'est pas question d'imaginer
la moindre cérémonie sans que la famille
ait donné son accord et y soient
associés
vous imaginez bien que c'est pas
aujourd'hui je sais que le président est
en relation avec la famille de jean paul
belmondo mais ce n'est certainement pas
le moment de mettre ce sujet sous là sur
la table fanou père veut ni rien n'est
pas les guignols
que là j'en ai ras-le-bol
enfin la nation lui rendra un hommage
national jeudi aux invalides c'est rare
plusieurs personnalités du monde de la
culture et ont eu droit charles aznavour
jean d'ormesson ou encore johnny
hallyday quelques heures après ce qu'on
vient d'entendre melville invectives à
nouveau vanel alors belmondo s'approche
du cinéaste lui ôte son chapeau et ses
lunettes et paf lui décoche une droite
qui le met ko par terre